[Music]
in canceled in sells news no they're so
funny
submitted by the shady Bunch Barcia
reddit changes harassment policies and
banned a major in cell community Wow why
is there a resident hate speech is there
like a like a thing that's going in cell
self proclaimed themselves like that
like I'm an insult kind of oh oh oh oh
is it the red pill one the red pill form
something like that okay oh those of you
don't know what in cells are its
involuntary celibate so these are men
that can't get laid and they blame women
and men in relationships for the reason
why they can't get why would they isn't
it kind of shameful to publicly admit
that no so there's no no no they're not
women they're not but then just saying
that I was like all because this insult
group got bad so in order to ban in
truth they must all say like it's kind
of like you're able to talk about your
struggles without people really knowing
who you are second on us there because
you okay [ __ ] yeah they don't want to
suck my dick yeah me too yeah me too
yeah down hashtag meets here think I'm
very psyched yeah like I mean this group
is so intense that even US military
issued a warning warning threats from in
cells planning to target the Joker at
the movie the reason tomorrow was appear
that Santa Barbara shooter or Santa was
a Santa Barbara visa in cell yeah and
the Denver gay right yeah what were they
gonna do with with the Joker movie
what's the threat so they were saying
that they were gonna go to the theaters
and shoot shoot him up or something why
Millett military I forgot which military
ratchet branch yet but they said that
beware be careful when Joker movie
because the Joker character is an insult
character and so that there might be
violence happening in the theatres and
because of Dark Knight Rises and the
like they're saying be careful when that
move I feel like they'll just line up
and watch the movie and be like finally
one of us are in the theater well I mean
they're getting violent
they have been violent man The Joker
movie then oh wait was it we're in all
the [ __ ] shooters recently like in
Texas and Ohio they were all in cells
right I don't know how many but I at
least know of the Santa Barbara one and
the Denver one
damn man see what happens when a guy
can't get laid you thought shooting [ __ ]
up connect this old fault
Joker's about an insult this version of
it I think Todd feels is portraying like
a guy who just has nothing and like
where women want to talk to him people
won't talk to him he's made fun of it's
basically like a lot of them I identify
with the job whereas other Joker is like
has Harley and she's pretty hot so but I
thought there was a black girl in the
Joker that he is like dating and stuff I
think there's a probably a turn where
she's like mmm oh like she friends owns
a bra yeah no spoilers I haven't seen
again neither it looks like a really
good movie it's amazing eight minute
standing ovation Wow Tribeca right
Venice all we're talking about here is
reddit and the fact that they have
announced that they will be broadening
their policies when it comes to threats
made on their sites and they
specifically significantly revised what
constitutes bullying and harassment oh
yeah don't forget to subscribe to us too
thank you
we're perfect timing hey Joe are you
okay don't forget to subscribe you know
why because we do so many articles on JK
news and I don't want you to miss it
yeah especially because the algorithm is
like a piece of garbage can so you need
to subscribe and right now make the bail
like and subscribers we're almost gonna
hit 2 million and then hit that
notification the bail okay now on to a
regularly scheduled in cell talk yes no
reddit
it's a Rosyth on ya insell roll Stephane
so reddit defines behavior in violation
of these rules as quote anything that
works to shut someone out of the
conversation through intimidation or
abuse online are off so previously they
shut down voting there's nothing down
voting is probably no but down 40 does
take you out of the conversation push
you down wouldn't necessarily be that
but they were saying that previously
they define bullying and harassment as
putting an individual of fear of their
real life safety or that a user no
longer feels that it is safe to post
online but now they're saying that
they're gonna tweak it so it could
pretty much they're saying that being
annoying downloading or disagreeing with
someone even strongly is not harassment
however menacing someone directing abuse
at a person or group following them
around the site encouraging others to do
any of these actions or otherwise
behaving in any in a way that would
discourage a reasonable person from
participating on reddit crosses the line
so now they're gonna be looking into
claims more seriously where they want to
when they want to there's all kinds of
subreddit sticking with all kind of
[ __ ] well that's really banned in
the brain cells brain cells as they're
called they're called brain soma
subreddit called brain cells so so yeah
I went down the rabbit hole to explore
this whole world in cell world yeah man
is really interesting because they have
their own beliefs about like why women
are the way they are and it's it's to me
it's like it's like the whole toxic
feminine thing like yeah but around yeah
it is a bunch of guy groups it's just
women only care about money and they
only care about Chad's yeah they think
that women do you scrap what the chat is
again so chad is like a muscular dude
like a Bart but taller no offense and
like they're like Chad's they got like
sick cars and they they have a cool
banking job or like a lawyer some [ __ ]
and like their [ __ ] win
they want to use well then which they
wish that the women would fall in love
with their fat bodies and I have damn
weak jaw lines yeah they have a whole
science doing that's where the mute
thing came from viewers yeah because of
like the so damaged don't do it as me
they have this whole graph of y like
girls like strong jaw lines and [ __ ] and
like yeah and then my mole and caveman
[ __ ] right it's funny dude so like they
have all these reasons why like girl
like they're just in cells and like
white girls can't get like they don't
want to see them instead of like making
themselves better and at the end of the
day they have no [ __ ] clue how women
are attracted to guys or anything like
that because it's all about the [ __ ]
energy and the charisma and then the
being able to confidence bro exactly an
Aryan victim mentality as well right so
all they see is here's this good-looking
guy that's tall and he could get girls
because I'm not a Chad like that yeah
and these girls just [ __ ] throw [ __ ]
at and the only like [ __ ] girls only
like [ __ ] I'm a good guy I'm a female
equivalent of an insult like there's
girls that always go toxic masculinity
toxic what's the girl version of that
Andrus me Andrus okay miss Andrus and in
cells just start dating or something
that would be awesome make an app that
they would yeah they couldn't get they
wouldn't get along they'll be fighting
each other all day all day nothing's
gonna work out think about like a
hardcore like feminist chick yeah
dating like a [ __ ] Republican senator
in a devout Christian like that's not
like emotionally they both don't
understand how the world works and
emotionally they're both they like to
victimize themselves so they have the
same type of driver as a human so I feel
like they would connect on a deeper
level maybe not like ideals why can't
though because they're already decided
that each other suck yeah that's like a
that's like a victim not I'm the victim
no I'm more of it
I already decided that you sucked you
already decided that I suck we ever have
a conversation or hang I see the
difference between cell and a guy that
just can't like a nerd who can't get
laid is that the in cells are blending
women where the other guys like I suck
well there's a whole philosophy behind
their biggest crossover so if I was an
insult went for it if I didn't blame but
then what happened is I've read that one
on YouTube it's like every guy's been in
are we in a dry spell or like maybe in
middle school like the girl that you
like doesn't like you I feel like every
guy has dabbled in - why doesn't she
like more she liked that dude that has
it yeah I think every guy has like a
slim has experienced the sliver of it
but I think people that are married to
that and their whole outlook is that now
I think that that's true because we've
all had a phase of involuntary syllabus
like we're not all like pussy's
available 24/7 if all dudes if all dudes
had it their way they probably have like
a thousand body count by the time
they're 14 what 13 yeah but I didn't and
I didn't want to either
I was always [ __ ] lame like that oh
you never wanted to bone everything
every teacher you saw every girl you saw
no just just scary so special and all
that kind of [ __ ] is low Sun
compared to Nikki opposites doing it
together somehow
I didn't slay more [ __ ] it should have
[ __ ] been slamming and slaying it and
slamming it so are these guys not
finding solutions I'm just trying to
understand you know if you think the
world is happening to you you're not out
trying to find the same so straight they
found their solution and their solution
is that women suck that's the solution
and then the Chad's that's a solution
this variation when I was in my Insull
phase apparently I was like [ __ ] it I
went on YouTube I said how to talk to a
girl what else - well you're not a in
cell so in cell is basically like
there's no hope
yes it's like I look this way I am I
don't have money so let me go and
complain with my other in cell phone and
we're smart and then those stupid chats
who watched Fast and Furious movies
which are
by the way [ __ ] Marines if you go
like no there's still a chance for me I
just got to figure out how to talk to
women that's a whole different group of
guys in cell guys are the guys that have
accepted their fate and they're like
there's no point for me even if I try my
hardest I'll never get laid
yes and this I get a ton of money within
that what they work towards yeah they
want to be super rich so they could buy
women or whatever so like dan Bilzerian
is like the most hated person and then
something for sure he's jacked well he's
also idolized though in a strange way by
in sales because he's rich as [ __ ] and
he's a womanizer and that's their dreams
we kind of like districts like women are
like disposable to him so he's like I
wish I could treat women like that yeah
exactly
I see do you know yeah existence if
you're an insole out there you should
check out the channel on YouTube simple
pickup it changed my life
they don't they don't they change their
videos now they don't exist anymore so
you're fun checked out betcha
no and if you're on reddit check out
Asian masculinity it's [ __ ] hilarious
what is that one it's another it's a pin
so that's a [ __ ] embarrassment bro
it's the red there's the white people
have gravy on that as well a lot of
white people have the red pill and then
this one's a asian master news this is
funny is that a Asian thing oh yeah
completely bro it's like the Asian you
it's like the Asian insel crew oh my god
yeah
[ __ ] man they're like we here's why
agents don't actually really technically
have small dicks and I'm like guess what
guys your confidence is your small dick
[ __ ] you yeah whistles sup some names in
Hollywood guess what guys I have a
friend who's five three and he was a
ladies man
[Music]